très bien m'écouter merci des de lui en
présentiel et nombreux en visio pour
cette conférence de presse
qu'ils signent donc la fin d'une
commission d' enquête sur contrôle des
ehpad
mais qui ne signe pas la fin du problème
et la fin et qui va comme l'a dit michel
mani tout à l'heure en questions
d'actualité au gouvernement qui va
nécessiter en effet que le gouvernement
prenne à bras le corps ce sujet mais je
vais passer dans c'est déjà la parole à
nos deux rapporteurs et qui commence
bernard
s'est pas séparé partida la parole au
niveau de la présentation on va voir un
peu en tout cas le nom on va lire le
texte qui résume un peu là là
l'intervention que nous avons au niveau
de la commission du sénat et puis après
je crois qu'il y avait des questions que
l'on pourra pas répondre et pour vous
donner un peu le ton général donc
l'émotion légitime suscitée par la
publication de deux ouvrages de lecteurs
castanet a conduit la commission des
affaires sociales du sénat à mettre en
place une mission d'information qui a
été dotée des pouvoirs de commission
denquête cette commission denquête s'est
inscrit dans le prolongement d'une
analyse des politiques de soutien
d'autonomie que nous poursuivions depuis
très longtemps vous savez que depuis
très longtemps on a fait beaucoup de
texte avec michel meunier du reste et
des rapports pour pousser vraiment le
gouvernement à mettre en place une loi
sur l'autonomie avant de vous présenter
nos conclusions il faut vous dire ce que
le rapport n'est pas ce n'est pas un
exercice d pad bashing au contraire je
crois qu'il fallait revaloriser
surtout tout le travail qui a été fait
par l'ensemble des personnels dans les
établissements et surtout de les mettre
en difficulté surtout dans la période
actuelle
et on voudrait les saluer surtout saluer
leur dévouement qui a été très important
et
les difficultés qu'ils ont pu avoir à
temps tous les états du reste qu'il soit
public privé privé que et puis privés
commerciaux
s'est tous et toutes ces difficultés
sont les mêmes dans les ehpad privés
commerciaux que dans les ehpad publics
je crois qu'il n'y a pas de différences
et des difficultés au niveau du nombre
de personnes qui aient sont aujourd'hui
très importante ce n'est pas non plus
une enquête sur la gestion des ehpad
orpea ce relais géré par le gouvernement
qui a saisi le procureur de la
république après la remise des
conclusions du rapport igas igf nous
travaux ont été consacrés à la question
du contrôle et même au contrôle du
contrôle et nous allons vous en
présenter brièvement les principales
conclusions vous dire d'abord que les
autorités de contrôle ne remplissent pas
leur mission en tout cas pas
suffisamment les contrôles existantes
étaient prioritairement axé sur la
maltraitance
c'est indispensable mais ça ne suffit
pas il faut absolument que le contrôle
et l'encadrement de l'activité des
groupes multi gestionnaires soit
renforcé pour permettre une meilleure
qualité de prise en charge des résidents
il faut étendre aussi la campagne de
contrôle annoncée par le gouvernement à
tous les groupes privés lucratifs on a
vu que le gouvernement souhaitait mettre
en place un contrôle de 7500 ehpad dans
les deux ans ce n'est pas pour nous la
priorité la priorité c'est surtout de
contrôler sur le plan financier
notamment tous les ehpad privé lucratif
parce qu on a parlé beaucoup d'orpea je
crois qu'il ya beaucoup à voir aussi au
niveau de tous les autres groupes privés
lucratifs et que le système qui n'est
peut-être pas aussi organisé que celui
d'orpea mérite quand même qu'on
s'attarde assez longuement sur les la
façon dont ils procèdent dans leurs
dents
la gestion des fonds publics qui leur
sont qui leur semble doté le rapport
igas igf a montré l'importance de ces
contrôles à un niveau agrégé sur un
certain nombre de sujets notamment les
remises de fin d'année la constitution
d'excédent les recrutements les
imputations budgétaires
donc il n'est plus suffisant de
contrôler les établissements il faut
donc surtout trouvé le moyen de
contrôler les groupes ce qui n'était pas
fait du tout jusqu'à aujourd'hui
ce cadre général posé on ne complétera
avec plusieurs mesures concrètes qui
visent à mieux encadrer l'activité des
groupes privés par exemple avec un
plafonnement des frais de siège et des
excédents et une pirogue clarification
des règles d'imputation budgétaire
je disais aussi que la recherche de
profit ne peut pas se faire au détriment
des résidents le commercial et le social
ne font pas toujours bon ménage et les
sites un peu antinomique parfois de voir
les deux
travaillé ensemble j'ai laissé ma
collègue peut-être continue et puis on
verra pour reprendre un peu son contrôle
efficace
un contrôle efficace nécessite également
de renforcer la coordination des acteurs
encore trop hétérogène selon les
départements nous proposons que la cns a
réuni 5 comité d'animation des contrôles
au niveau national qui réunira les
administrations centrales concernées les
caisses de sécurité sociale
le défenseur des droits l'adf afin de
concevoir des orientations communes ou
coordonner et de donner des impulsions
au réseau de déconcentrer ce comité
d'animation doit être déclinée au niveau
départemental avec un représentant du
conseil départemental
le renforcement et la structuration des
contrôles doivent aller de pair avec un
renouvellement des pratiques en matière
de pilotage stratégique et notamment sur
la délivrance des autorisations ce
fameux droit d'opposition des autorités
en cas de transfert redevance plaçons
plafonnement de l'offre aux autres
propositions c'est dans notre rapport à
moyen terme malgré tous les moyens
engagés pour réussir le virage
domiciliaire et le succès déjà engrangés
en la matière les besoins de places en
ehpad le besoin de places en ehpad va
continuer à s'accroître dans les années
à venir il faudra ouvrir 56 mines place
environ d'ici
2030 en ehpad il est donc fondamental
d'investir massivement dans la
modernisation du bac qui les ehpad
surtout public dont le bâti est plus
ancien et de réfléchir au moyen de leur
donner pour faciliter à leurs données
pour faciliter le portage de leur
immobilier par exemple via la
possibilité de s'appuyer sur des
professionnels tels les offices publics
d'attaché l'aiment ou des foncières
solidaire pour les accompagner dans la
gestion de ce patrimoine
une réflexion doit être en cours
doit en outre pardon être ouverte sur la
pertinence des dispositifs fiscaux
visant à favoriser l'investissement
privé dans le secteur et les rapporteurs
nous interrogeons sur l'opportunité de
restreindre très sérieusement les
mécanismes de défiscalisation de
l'investissement locatif en ehpad ses
remarques sur le pilotage de l'offre
nous conduisent naturellement à évoquer
les questions de gouvernance
l'association des usagers au
fonctionnement des établissements médico
sociaux a longtemps était balbutiante
avec le décret du 25 avril
2022 tout récemment le gouvernement a
apporté d'opportunes précision ces
clarifications sont bienvenus mais elle
ne lève pas tous les obstacles à la
bonne marche de ses organes de
représentation et de concertation la
présence d'associations agréées devait
devraient être envisagées sur le modèle
des associations d'usagers dans le
secteur sanitaire par exemple nous
rejoignons nos collègues de l'assemblée
nationale sur la nécessité de créer un
conseil national consultatif des
personnes âgées sur le modèle existant
du conseil national consultatif des
personnes handicapées ce conseil
favorisera l'expression des associations
avec la place des usagers la question de
la gouvernance est dominée par une autre
problématique celle de la simplification
du pilotage territorial alors oui vous
savez qu'aujourd'hui dans le pilotage
qui mise en place du des ehpad on a
trois tours à tarif quel tarif de la
médicalisation qui est mise en place par
les ars de tarifs de la dépendance qui
mise en place par des départements il
t'arrive de d'hébergement qui mise en
place soit par les départements dans le
cas des établissements publics ou privés
associatifs qui ennuie ce qu'on appelle
la méditation en aide sociale soit par
les privés lorsque si du privé
commercial or une fois absolument
simplifiée et nous pensons que tous les
ans fatou le string et les structures
habilitées à recevoir des personnes
dépendantes demande à ce qu'une
simplification de ces règles et qu'on
puisse n'avoir qu'un financeurs un seul
financeur pour au moins ce qui concerne
la dépendance et le soin donc on propose
effectivement que les départements
puissent avoir cette compétence dans la
mesure où l'intérêt c'est de mettre en
place un parcours de 2 sous un parcours
de vie des personnes âgées et qu'on
puisse traiter à la fois le domicile les
résidences intermédiaires et les
structures que type ehpad donc on
propose que les une organisation sera
mise en place pour qu'ils y ait un seul
tarificateur quant à l'hébergement il
faut qu'on puisse le contrôler ces les
propositions que nous avons fait le
rapport il faut absolument que ce que
l'on a appelé aujourd'hui le secret des
affaires soient levés pour tout ce qui
concerne les résidents dans des
établissements médico sociaux il faut
pas qu'on nous oppose ce secret des
affaires pour ne pas connaître et que
les résidents ne puisse pas s'interroger
sur ce qui leur est offert dans le
problème de l'hébergement et de la
restauration ça on demande aussi qu'il y
ait une clarification et qu'on puisse le
contrôler au niveau de ceux qui seront
appelés justement à mettre en place les
contrôles des établissements
il faut
aussi alors justement le vous avez tous
entre tout entendu parler de la mission
dominique libault qui avait préconisé
beaucoup de choses dans la
mise en place d'une loi grand âge
dominique libault a refait une
rapport récemment pour justement proposé
la mise en place d'un comité territorial
pour l'autonomie qui permettrait
justement de mettre en place tous les
acteurs à la fois pour
organiser la prise en charge des
personnes en perte d'autonomie et
surtout pour clarifier
cette
cette tarification des différents
secteurs soit indépendance
le pilotage par la qualité nous semble
aussi très important et ça le pilotage
par la qualité il est dans tous les
établissements alors on a remarqué que
tous les établissements jeudi au départ
sont en difficulté par manque de
personnel parce que tous les
établissements ont des difficultés dans
l'attractivité du métier tous les
établissements ont un manque de
personnel évident parce comme dans l'ain
verse de beaucoup d'autres pays on
manque de personnel dans des
établissements pour s'occuper des
personnes en perte d'autonomie il faut
donc qu'une loi grand âge permettent
justement de mettre les moyens
suffisants pour que les établissements
et plus de personnel à disposition mais
il faut aussi qu'on puisse vérifier la
qualité donc dans tous les
établissements les 7500 établissements
de france et qu'on puisse contrôler en
parallèle le financement des groupes
privés lucratifs en particulier
la dernière proposition donc elle
étonnera personne je crois que enfin
avant le dernier policier on a parlé
aussi la maltraitance il faut absolument
que tous les cas de maltraitance soit
traité un peu comme en a traité les
maltraitances 24,2 de la protection de
l'enfance il faut que tout soit
centralisé un endroit mais qu'il y ait
une réponse apportée à ceux qui ont
signalé des cas de maltraitance ce qui
n'est pas le cas aujourd'hui et puis la
dernière proposition c'est celle dont on
parle depuis longtemps et dans michel
meunier a posé toutes les rues la
première questions d'actualité au
gouvernement au nouveau ministre de
l'autonomie quand c'est mettrez-vous en
place la loi sur l'autonomie qu'on
attend tous on sait tous ce qu'il faut
faire mais par contre on veut que les
moyens soient mis en face des
propositions qui ont été faites par les
uns et les autres voilà ce qu'on
souhaitait dire mais bon il ya tout le
rapport effectivement qui a été long on
a interrogé énormément de personnes on a
rencontré beaucoup beaucoup de monde est
ce que voulait dire aussi avec michel
meunier c'est qu'on remercie quand même
victor castanet et on remercie
l'infirmier qui a été à l'origine un peu
de cette dénonciation il ya des
exagérations considérable les
détournements d'argent public
il faut absolument qu'on n'arrête le
système qui a été mis en place qu'on
trouve les moyens de contrôler et il
faut que
ce qui s'est passé qui n'étaient pas
connus pas connu en tout cas des
différents services que ce soit rs ou
département et bien qu'on puisse les
contrôler les surveiller et les empêcher
de faire ce qu'ils ont fait voilà merci
donc nous allons pouvoir répondre à vos
questions qu'ils souhaitent commencer
des questions en visio des questions
visio vous levez la main
oui alors allez vous présenter peut
poser votre question céline quinny cosco
[Musique]
comme type de contrôle parce qu'il peut
y avoir plein dax de contrôle différents
donc est-ce que vous pouvez nous
détailler ce qui vous paraissent
prioritaires
dans le rapport il est dit que ce qui a
manqué beaucoup c'est l'organisation des
contrôles il y à des contrôles qui ont
été mises en place mais par différentes
qui était en silo et il ya différentes
organismes d'état voire départementaux
aussi qu'ils contrôlaient mais de
manière indépendante et sans aucune
coordination
donc ce que l'on veut mettre en place et
une coordination autour de deux ans avec
ses contrôles et que tous les tous ceux
qui seront appelés à intervenir dans les
établissements puissent absolument se
rencontrer et permettent aussi de de
comparer un peu les difficultés que les
uns et les autres peuvent avoir on
souhaite aussi que les contrôles au
niveau financier n'est pas fait
aujourd'hui soit beaucoup plus
précis aujourd'hui ce qui a été mis en
place par orpea est peut-être pas que
d'autres on verra après c'est une
centralisation excessive de tous les
deux tout leur système les directeurs
locaux n'avait aucune autonomie et tout
remonter au niveau régional voire au
niveau national et personne ne contrôler
le niveau national et les flux
financiers qui intervenait entre
l'argent public et l'argent des
résidents étaient totalement opaque ils
ont organisé ce système alors bien sûr
ils disent on n'a pas organisé la
maltraitance mais en organisant ce
système de détournement d'argent public
ça entraîné une maltraitance au niveau
des résidents donc il faut absolument
qu'on puisse contrôler les groupes au
siège au niveau du siège et non plus au
niveau de chaque établissement et pour
compléter ce que vient de dire vers
narbonne le contrôle
il est vraiment très pauvre et c'est pas
trahir ni juger de la qualité de ceux
qui contrôlent assez simplement
l'absence de moyens les ars ont perdu à
peu près 10% ou 15% dans de leurs
effectifs dans ses dix dernières années
la fonction de contrôle n'était pas une
priorité il faut le dire
quand on n'auditionnait des responsables
d directrice ou directeur d'ehpad il
avait peu d'exemples de contrôle
peut-être on disait en moyenne un tous
les vingt ans voire 30 ans enfin vous
voyez c'est à ce niveau là donc remettre
du contrôle c'est pas un vain mot mais
c'est vraiment une action qui est
indispensable
de politique publique et qui n'a pas
lieu et donc voilà simplement
ce besoin important d'encadrer de
contrôler et ensuite de sanctionner
parce que ça aussi ça fera partie des
recommandations quand il y a constat de
déviance de dévoiement de
2,2 des dysfonctionnements il faut qu'il
y ait à la clé une sanction ce qui
n'existe pas forcément aujourd'hui
et essayer d'autres questions je crois
qu'il y avait peut-être des jb après
jérôme peut-être oui bonjour
j'essaie de faire fonctionner la caméra
mais je suis pas sûr d'y être arrivé
excusez moi
je voudrais vous demander si vous
pourriez clarifier en aval j'ai pas un
comme le rapporte vous fait d'avoir été
clarifiée exactement la portée des
contrôles qu'est-ce que
financiers des établissements
aujourd'hui
nature des contrôles qu'est-ce que
contrôlent les airs et c'est ce qu'elles
font contrôler la fiabilité des comptes
they are des les opèrent des
autres questions attendez on va d'abord
on va d'abord répondre peut-être assez
de questions parce qu'elle est
importante justement c'est tout le
problème c'est que les ars contrôler les
oeufs perdre et les yeux et regarder
mais uniquement par rapport à des
chiffres qui leur étaient donnés sans
les contrôler sans aller plus avant dans
ce qui était proposé par les structures
or
les au niveau régional et surtout au
niveau national parce qu'on parle des
groupes je parle du groupe au niveau
national à l'organisation nationale de
tous les ehpad il y avait une opacité
complète sur les flux financiers qui
intervenait entre les différents
établissements donc aujourd'hui on s'est
aperçu que les 1eres contrôler les
établissements sur la qualité il donnait
un certain des montants qu'ils allaient
vérifier si les montants étaient bien
les pensées ce qui était le cas en
général mais par contre il vérifié pas
des flux qui intervenait entre les
établissements voire entre les
établissements et le groupe et c'est là
où on s'est aperçu que aucun contrôle
n'est effectué au niveau des groupes au
niveau du siège et qu'il faut absolument
pouvoir contrôler le siège parce que
c'est là où les manipulations
financières ont été des plus importantes
si on parle par exemple de rfa les
fameuses ristourne de fin d'année on
appelle aussi les les comme il les
appelle maintenant les les
prestations de services pense qu'il est
un peu une fumisterie mais les les les
prix sont de fins d'années était donné
au niveau du siège s'était pas donné au
niveau des établissements donc c'est là
tout le problème de cette connaissance
de du financement qui était au niveau de
chaque établissement et qui remontait au
siège et qu'on ne contrôlait pas
pour compléter ce que ce qui vient
d'être dit c'est que c'est un type de
contrôle peut et devra en enclencher un
autre dans un autre domaine sur le même
établissement je pense par exemple au
contrôle du travail droit du travail et
regarder les contrats regarder les
horaires regarder le nombre la qualité
de même pareil pour
le contrôle sur la répression des
fraudes voir la qualité les facturations
enfin voyez donc parce que ce qu'on
s'est aperçu c'est que ce fonctionnement
très individualisé spécialiste dans son
domaine
faisait qu'on ne parlait pas du reste or
c'est souvent des pratiques qui sont
complexes qui sont mêlés qui sont dans
un système et puis je crois aussi sur
tous les établissements enfin des
établissements le groupe le groupe a
réussi justement à faire
profiter
profitez le siège de financement public
en n'utilisant pas totalement les fonds
publics pour ce pourquoi ils devaient
très peu utilisé et en se servant de cet
argent public pour financer de
l'hébergement qui revenait après au
niveau du groupe j'essaye d'expliquer le
la rs donne à mon temps pour les soins
le département un montant pour les
l'indépendance son temps correspond à
des
normes au niveau des équivalents temps
plein des personnes qui y travaillent et
puis un nombre de personnes qui
travaillaient aussi pour l'hébergement
et la restauration
or il y avait une opacité totale entre
le passage des uns vers les autres qui
fait que beaucoup de d'argent public
servait en fait à payer du personnel
pour l'hébergement et donc revenez dans
les résultats du groupe et tout cet
argent cette récupération d'argent ou
même des excédents qui étaient mises en
place par les groupes par les sièges ne
revenait jamais aux résidents
les l'histoire des refa dont on a parlé
les régions de fin d'année
normalement ce que l'on souhaite si vous
arrivez en achetant un grand nombre de
matériels comme tous les commerciaux le
fonds à réduire le prix de 10 20 ou 30%
il faut que le résidents puissent en
profiter c'est de l'argent public or eux
il faisait payer à l'établissement le
prix fort à 100% et la ristourne de fin
d'année elle allait au siège et ne
revenez pas du tout aux résidents et les
prestations soit disantes services
n'étaient pas des prestations de
services qui étaient réels la plupart du
temps et donc ça servait plutôt à
alimenter le compte des actionnaires
plutôt que la qualité de vie des
résidents alors il ya d'autres questions
on va les prendre comme ça
avant vous aviez une deuxième question
les i oui
il m'a semblé entendre comprends que
vous vouliez me proposiez une réforme de
la gouvernance qui consisterait à si
j'ai bien compris à ce que le
département se substitue aujourd'hui aux
ars pour tarifer à pour fixer leur
enveloppe qui sera donné aux ehpad pour
financer le soin ce que j'ai bien
compris et c'est c'est considérable
comme vous comme réforme serait
l'intérêt aujourd'hui c'est pas du tout
dans l'air du temps ce que vous proposez
laruns
sais pas si c'est j'ai bien compris
si vous ne connaissez bien c'est pas le
premier rapport que nous faisons bernard
bonne et moi et on est un peu sur la
même longueur d'onde là dessus c'est à
dire que plus il ya de financeurs et
plus ça devient non seulement compliqué
pour la gestion mais ça devient donc là
on le voit la possibilité aussi de
d'échapper à certaines règles et de
passer dans les mailles du filet donc on
est pour que un responsable d pad est
une
un seul interlocuteur et que ce soit au
niveau du département que ça se passe
puisque même si des grands groupes
existent et que ça on ne demande pas
leur arrêt
c'est vraiment la proximité qui compte
pour les familles pour les personnes
elles-mêmes puisqu'on parle de plus en
plus maintenant de d'avancement dans
l'ag de parcours avec des possibilités
de rentrer chez soi rée c'est ce soit
être spécialisés un peu à être en
établissement enfin bref donc la
proximité c'est le département mais les
ars on reconnaît aussi que dans le
domaine de la santé c'est une
organisation quand même qui est bon
échelon dans et il remet pas en cause le
fonctionnement mais sûrement une
organisation qui soit plus
responsabilisés autour dans le quotidien
autour du département bernard s'il veut
des l'idée de simplifier c'est pas de
supprimer la rs et de supprimer les
prérogatives de la rs mais ce que l'on
souhaite qui n'est pas écrit dans le
texte mais ce qu'on souhaite c'est
simplifier cette gouvernance en tout cas
pour que le directeur le responsable
local d'un établissement n'est qu'un
seul interlocuteur et l'idée serait par
exemple de dire au niveau des arrêts
sans détermine pour chaque département
un montant de soins à apporter parce que
le montant des choix il est à peu près
équivalent pour tous les résidents dans
tous les établissements un montant de
soi au niveau des départements et que de
responsables ars territoriale de chaque
département travaille avec le président
du département pour déterminer h dans
chaque établissement quel est le montant
qui leur est attribuée ça permettrait de
simplifier d'arrêter les complications
entre ce qui relève du soin de la
dépendance de mettre du personnel en
place avec l'argent public et après de
contrôler ce qui relève de l'hébergement
et de la restauration
c'est ça c'est simplifier au maximum
pour éviter toutes ces contraintes
administratives
vous savez qui fait que les personnes
passent plus de temps dans leur bureau
compris les résidents de
deux micros étaient un micro
appuyé sur
un icône est journaliste indépendante
oui justement là le système de
financement par lé département ça existe
déjà au niveau de la zone la ze et
senans c'est un département mais il y a
des problèmes comment allez vous faire
pour avoir la certitude que le contrôle
sera bien effectuer ces différents au
niveau de la zone tout est financé par
le département et la participation de
l'état n'est n'est pas donné au
département mais pas à chaque
établissement alors il ya des problèmes
comme partout dès qu'il y a des du
médico-social et des fonds publics il ya
on peut dire qu'il ya toujours des
problèmes et dans les départements il ya
des attributions qui sont donnés à
chaque établissement par un seul
financeur c'est à dire que les
interlocuteurs n'ont qu'un seul
financeur en face de ces deux
départements là aujourd'hui ils ont dans
deux voire quelquefois un peu plus et ce
qu'on voudrait simplifiée c'est
justement cette pas divergences parce
qu'il ya souvent il ya un accord entre
le service de rs et le département mais
que le il n'est pas plusieurs dossiers à
remplir et pour la rs et pour le
département ont rempli un dossier qui
sert à tout le monde et y ait un seul
financeur qui leur attribue les défendre
en public
laso c'est différent la zone il n'y a
pas de participation de l'état au niveau
de la zone enfin pas directement
voilà il y avait une question de madame
le bris apm vous le souhaitez la pause
et où cela bonjour
à les y aller j'irai
préciser comment se déclinerait cette
nouvelle mission confiée la sienne et ça
et sur le plan des moyens de la
coordination
comment vous proposer de renforcer les
moyens des beaux murs sans trop de temps
en matière de deux volumes que de
compétences puissent effectivement les
auditions montré qu'il fallait des
compétences budgétaires et
financières etc
voilà donc comment est ce que vous
proposez aussi sur glace que vous
proposez aussi de réformer les
inspections
les inspections des ars flambeau les
inspections des ars la façon dont il
voit dans cette mission est organisée et
financée
la scène et ça aujourd'hui n'a pas n'a
pas un rôle de mission de contrôle on
voudrait simplement qu'elle organise au
niveau national le contrôle qui pourrait
être mis en place dans tous les
départements mais c'est pas elle qui
fera le contrôle mais on voudrait qu'ils
l'organisation quand que les choses
soient soit clair au niveau de chacun rs
chaque département mais que c'est que ce
contrôle soit fait et organisé par la
cnss a qui devrait prendre de plus en
plus d'importance par rapport au secteur
médico social et notamment au secteur
d'autonomie dans le cadre de la 5ème
branche qui a été créé
et puis la scène et ça permettrait aussi
de contrôler la cns aurait pour rôle de
contrôler les groupes ce qui aujourd'hui
n'est pas fait et ne peut pas être fait
par les rs y avait plusieurs
possibilités soit
une agence régionale de santé
prendraient un groupe particulier
privées et notre ère s en prendre à un
autre mais là le plus simple c'est de
confier à la cns a le soin de contrôler
les groupes ou d'organiser en tout cas
le contrôle des groupes pour qu'ils
puissent le faire en direct ce serait
eux qui piloterait ce contrôle au niveau
des groupes pour être sûr et certain
qu'il soit fait en ce qui concerne
madame les ars pour vous regarderez de
près les auditions qu'on a mené sur
plusieurs agences régionales de santé
quand ils nous donnent les chiffres du
cor des contrôleurs et quand qu'il
ramène à l'action réellement dédié aux
contrôles on s'est presque du simple au
double c'est à dire de mémoire je ne
sais quelle agence régionale de santé je
pense que c'est l'île de france peut
nous annoncer
200 plus de 200 contrôleurs mais
réellement 27 sur le contrôle des
leviers dans les ehpad donc vous voyez
c'est là on s'aperçoit et on constate
bien encore une fois que le contrôle ne
faisait pas partie des missions
prioritaires des agences régionales de
santé
or justement quelles sont que sont vos
propositions pour remédier à ce problème
là au delà de la coordination et des
décos des compétences de chacun
les propositions que l'on fait elles ont
pour but d'être une fête des mesures
dans l'ensemble d'une loi qui traite du
grand âge et de la perte d'autonomie et
dans cette loi doit figurer les moyens
qui seront mis pour accueillir des
personnes en ehpad par exemple et donc
avec ses moyens il faudra déterminer le
nombre de contrôles ça doit faire partie
d'une action
une action de prise en charge des
personnes pour l'instant ne l'est pas
l'encadrement également et la sanction
comme je les dis c'est vraiment le truc
une action
comptable des deniers publics qui sont
engagées pour la prise en charge ça et
le principe on a surtout voulu mettre en
avant que les contrôles ont été mal fait
que les contrôles n'ont pas été fait au
niveau des groupes qu'on a manqué
complètement la mission de contrôle de
l'argent public dans les grands groupes
et qu'il faut qu'il ait une coordination
cette coordination doit être fait alors
organisé par organisé par la cns a au
niveau national pour les groupes est
organisé au niveau territorial au niveau
départemental en mettant tous les
acteurs en place et en les faisant se
rencontrer
aujourd'hui tout à l'heure michel
meunier n'a l'a rappelé il ya beaucoup
de contrôles qui sont effectués dans les
établissements qui sont effectués
indépendamment les uns des autres il n'y
a pas de coordination
donc au niveau départemental cette
coordination sera mise en place mais en
ce qui concerne les groupes et notamment
les groupes privés commerciaux il faut
que la scène et ça organise le contrôle
elle ne fera pas elle-même elle
organisera le contrôle alors soit avec
les ars avec une ars avait plusieurs
mais il faut qu'elles organisent le
contrôle de ces groupes et qu'on puisse
éviter les
erreurs considérables qui ont été faites
jusqu'à maintenant
[Musique]
non non au niveau territorial
la proposition du rapport libos qui
vient de sortir à du 22 mars justement
confierait au niveau du département du
président du département la présidence
de ce comité d'organisation comité de
contrôle comme des mets qui serait
coprésidée par le représentant
territorial de la rs on nous a laissé on
est très proche de sa proposition qui
s'appelle conférence territoriale
pour les personnes âgées c'est une une
recommandation de propositions que
avons fait nôtre oui ils appellent ça la
côte est a donc on parlera plutôt de la
côte et à dans quelques temps un corps
ni à saint territoriales pour
l'autonomie dont qui permettra justement
localement de coordonnées intelligemment
les contrôles parce que comme on l'a dit
moi je le répète on en a parlé le
gouvernement a parlé pour se rattraper
j'allais dire des 7500 contrôle dans les
deux ans on pense que c'est excessif que
les contrôles on n'a pas besoin d'aller
embêter tous les directeurs de france et
de navarre qui font bien leur boulot
mais qui manque surtout de moyens voilà
surtout besoin de contrôler les
androïdes la maltraitance quant à les
signaler et les endroits où justement il
ya de l'argent public et donner sans
qu'il y ait eu des contrôles suffisants
jusqu'à maintenant et tous les groupes
privés commerciaux
je crois que c'est ça l'important demain
c'est de contrôler ce qui n'a pas été
contrôlé aujourd'hui est d'aider enfin
et puis de faire une grande tâche qui
permettra aux directeurs d'avoir un peu
plus de moyens pour justement
éviter toute maltraitance
oui une question d' hélène chevalier
pour france inter
hélène chevalier
vous faudrait appuyer
appuyé sur votre micro pour parler
peut-être
vous nous entendez ou pas
pendant
l apal micro
d'interviews nombre de contrôles elle
demande le nombre de contrôles contrôle
qu'on organiserait ya pas de chiffres il
n'y a pas de chiffre précis je crois
qu'il faut contrôler très fortement et
régulièrement tous les groupes privés
commerciaux au niveau du siège comme on
l'a dit et les établissements de façon
aléatoire comme on le faisait plus
fréquemment qu'on ne le fait aujourd'hui
et surtout dès qu'il y a des cas de
maltraitances de kylie a des cas de
difficultés dans un établissement il
faut les contrôler il faut garder aussi
les contrôles inopinés qui sont
importants je crois que des contrôles
inopinés coordonnées doivent être mis en
place plus régulièrement mais organisé
par département avec bien sûr le le
délégué territorial de la rs il faut que
ce soit organisée
au niveau départemental
oui vous les posez une question
oui c'était sur le l'autorisation la
délivrance d'autorisations très
importante on s'en est aperçu que qu'il
y avait énormément
d'autorisation de transfert qui avait
été fait un peu
rapidement sans véritablement une étude
approfondie et que les groupes privés
commerciaux
n'ont pas eu beaucoup de créations ex
nihilo de place par quand ils ont eu une
augmentation du nombre de places très
importante ces dix dernières années par
cl en racheter des structures et là il
faut absolument que le contrôle on
voudrait contrôler en proposent dans
leur apport dans les propositions de ne
plus autoriser systématiquement les
transferts de les contrôler beaucoup
plus en demande aussi de ne pas dépasser
un certain pourcentage
par rapport à ce qui existe en deux
structures privées commerciales et donc
tout ça c'est à chiffrer on l'a pas
chiffré on dit qu'il faut absolument
qu'on limite l'expansion de ces
structures privées commerciales
parce qu'il est souhaitable que le
public puisse prendre toute sa place et
garder toute sa place on pense aussi que
le public a été gêné et n'a pas pu
répondre à des projets parce qu'il avait
des difficultés sur le plan immobilier
donc il faut donner plus de moyens au
niveau du public pour que la partie
immobilière ne soit pas un obstacle
et il faut pas que les groupes privés
avec des difficultés qu'on a eu et
et le les difficultés qu'on a eu et les
difficultés du contrôle puisse perdurer
ou recommencer et puis surtout il faut
le dire est ce que vous avez une
différence de prix entre les structures
privées commerciales les structures
publiques c'est énorme donc il faut
qu'on essaie d'atténuer au maximum cette
différence de prix qui est qui est
considérable quand des structures
privées commerciales voudront faire de
la très bonne qualité au niveau des
personnes offriront des prestations
hôtelières qui soit supérieur aux autres
pourquoi pas il faut les contrôler mais
pourquoi pas par contre il faut essayer
de développer au maximum les structures
publiques donc les
le prix pour les résidents est
acceptable pour les retraités que nous
avons aujourd'hui en france la logique
financière des groupes
donc voilà l'objectif c'est de faire de
l'argent
n'a d'obsession que d'être rentable et
donc le taux d'occupation est leur
boussole donc on arrive parfois à avoir
des taux d'occupation qui sont plus de
100 % quand on connaît le monde du
médico-social et des ehpad en
particulier on sait que 100 % c'est
quasiment impossible puisque de manière
très pragmatique quand il ya le départ
d'une personne âgée que ce soit par
décès ou par par hospitalisation
c'est pas le lendemain que sa chambre
est occupé donc il ya toujours un
battement que plus ou moins occupés or
là au niveau des groupes dans les
auditions qu'on a pu les témoignages
qu'on a pu entendre ce n'est pas
entendable et il faut que ce soit 100 %
d'occupation donc que fond
ces gestionnaires soit il rajoute delhi
où ils font de la place on a eu des
exemples de tisanerie qui ont été
transformés en chambres enfin bon c'est
on dit c'est pas le modèle de
d'établissement qu'on souhaite pour nos
aînés c'est pas de ça dont il s'agit il
s'agit de bientraitance d'accompagnement
de la personne âgée est de faire en
sorte qu'elles vivent au mieux ses vieux
jours comme comme on dit or là on est
dans une logique de ne pas perdre
d'argent ou au contraire faire gagner de
l'argent pour ses actionnaires quand le
groupe est coté en bourse comme il en
existait comme c'est le cas pour orpea
donc ces deux logiques qui sont
en tout cas contradictoires et l'éthique
nous demandent de reparler la prise en
charge des personnes âgées de manière
digne et non pas comptable et financière
s'il vous plaît si une famille signalé
un cas de maltraitance à qui doit elle
s'annonce s'adresser aux départements au
responsable territorial de la rsa qui
alors l'idée c'est de mettre un numéro
unique oui et qu'il n'y ait pas
aujourd'hui il y à 3-3 façon de signaler
les maltraitances et il faut qu'il y en
ait qu'une seule et qu'on puisse
adresser directement alors soit au
département on l'a pas précisé il faut
bien une structure unique qui puisse
traiter tous les cas de maltraitance et
ce qui est important surtout c'est que
dès qu'il ya un cas de maltraitance on
s'en occupe c'est pour ça qu'au niveau
terme on pense qu'au niveau
départemental ça serait une bonne
solution mais qu'on s'en occupe même si
c'est au niveau national mais que ça
redescendre au niveau départemental et
surtout qu' une réponse apportée à celui
qui a signalé la maltraitance en canter
on a fait la loi sur la protection de
l'enfance on a justement mis ça en place
l'obligation lorsqu'il y avait un
signalement de maltraitance de donner
une réponse à celui qui avait signalé la
maltraitance et quand je dire oui on
s'en est occupé oui on a traité ou alors
ne pas lui donner la solution qui a été
trouvée mais dire oui on s'en est occupé
à tellement mans et voilà alors
qu'aujourd'hui ça n'est pas fait et puis
il faut aussi que des cas de
maltraitance soit vraiment signalé parce
qu'on s'est aperçu aussi dans les
groupes privés notamment orpea est bien
des cas de maltraitance qui étaient
traités plus ou moins selon les cas et
que c'était un peu en fonction de leur
bon vouloir du directeur régional voire
national qu'on décider si oui ou non
tels cas a été traité
c'est inadmissible
cela faire payer une redevance
c'est un maillon de l'océan c'est une
idée c'est pas la plus importante c'est
pas la plus importante et c'est de dire
effectivement certains ont proposé qu'il
y ait une redevance qui soit versée à
partir du moment où c'est un organisme
commerciale qui est à but lucratif il
n'y a pas de raison lui donne une
possibilité d'avoir des deux
d'avoir des revenus
y'a pas de raison qu'ils ne payent pas
une redevance alors une redevance au
départ une fois une seule fois au monde
la création mais elle paie une redevance
on l'a mis en place parce que c'était
souhaitée par beaucoup d'acteurs sais
pas c'est pas la partie la plus
importante du rapport c'est pas le
l'obligation qu'ont art absolument mais
je pense qu'il faut réfléchir à cette
possibilité et qu'elle pourrait quand
même permettre par exemple de faciliter
par le paiement d'une redevance bien le
paiement de l'immobilier pour des
établissements publics par exemple
question de ouest france et c'est quoi
je suis si vous permettez sur les
transferts
mais qui qui serait amené à décider sur
pour cette idée on est parti du constat
que parfois un président de département
découvre que les pas de la changer de
gestionnaire excès plus l'association
intel mais une autre notre association
ou un groupe qui gère les ehpad et donc
ça sans passer par
la case départ de tout projet de
création donc là il ya une anomalie qui
fait dire que si on change ciara chasser
ici il ya transfert d'exploitation comme
on dit il faut redemander à la rs
l'accréditation mais l'autorisation vous
demandez qui si on met en place un
comité territorial de l'autonomie ça
serait ce comité territorial qui
déciderait au niveau départemental
c'était comme des départementales je le
répète présidée par le président du
département et avec un vice président
qui est le délégué ars
territoriale et ce serait eux qui
décident
alors il eu
alors la coordination des contrôles mais
c'est pas obligatoire eux qui feraient
les contrôles c'est je crois justement
que souvent le problème
est que le tarificateur fait le contrôle
en même temps il faudrait peut-être
mieux que ce soit un autre
organe ici contrôle mais que
l'organisation du contrôle soit faite au
niveau de ce comité territorial
sabre on l'a pas précisé parce que je
crois que c'est à mettre en place après
il faut absolument que ce contrôle soit
fait soit organisé sur le plan
territorial sur le plan départemental
qu'ils soient coordonnées mais après la
mise en place ceux qui feront le
contrôle à mon avis c'est plutôt les
seules ars légendaire s avec la cour des
comptes la chambre régionale des comptes
a proposé effectivement sur plans
financiers de s'en occuper beaucoup plus
je crois que ce sera important aussi
parce qu'ils ont des moyens qui sont
considérables on l'a vu dans la mission
igas igf ils ont en deux mois fait un
travail extraordinaire
partout en france pour contrôler et ils
ont vu tout ce qui cloche et ils ont
confirmé tout ce que le livre de victor
keystone et/ou sommes à 90 % - tout ce
victor castanet avait annoncé dans son
livre et l'audit interne qui a été
promis en place par orpea lui-même
audit interne tout à fait indépendants
confirment aussi tout ce qui a été dit
pratiquement dans le rapport igas igf
mais quand on voit et quand on entend et
quand lee ça on est un peu peut-être que
révoltée
céline bardy
est-ce que vous pouvez mettre d'autres
micro
très bien
bonjour
vous avez évoqué le journal quel journal
ouest france parle vous avez évoqué la
nécessité des moyens à mettre dans la
loi inscrire dans la loi pour permettre
toutes les préconisations vous êtes en
train de faire est ce que vous les avez
chiffré ses moyens ou bien il faudrait
pour comprendre là il il ya deux sortes
de moyens y a les moyens de contrôle et
puis les moyens pour les ehpad dans le
cas de la loi grand âge c'est différent
c'est de l'ordre de 8 à 10 milliards
pour le pour la loi grand âge et c'est
au niveau des contrôles le jour n'a pas
chiffré du tout je crois qu'il faut
augmenter le nombre de personnes dans
chaque ars pour contrôler il faut des
personnes soient affectées
peut-être pas uniquement au contrôle des
établissements médico sociaux mais en
tout cas qu'il y ait plus de personne
qui puisse s'en occuper jean n'a pas
chiffré parce qu'on sera pas compte du
temps qu'il faut passer dans chaque
établissement en tout cas il faut les
renforcer parce que tous les inspecteurs
les corps d'inspecteurs pharmaciens
médecins et et corps d'inspecteurs nous
ont dit que depuis plusieurs années il y
avait une diminution du nombre
une insuffisance en tout cas de
recrutement et qu'il faut absolument
pallier cette difficulté
notre rapport est donc vraiment sur le
contrôle du contrôle donc on a développé
plusieurs éléments dans ce sens il
savait le gouvernement il dispose d'une
petite quinzaine de rapports sur les
ehpad les métiers du grand âge vieillir
à domicile
et que sais-je encore donc et y compris
le financement et sa cette somme là dont
on vient de parler bernard bonne estimé
à autour de 10 milliards d'euros
annuels ça le gouvernement le sait aussi
c'est des chiffres qui circulent à la
fois des associations du cns a lui même
aussi sur le contrôle sur les moyens à
mettre en place dans le contrôle on n'a
pas chiffré il faut un nombre de postes
que je sharif a estimé par un rs en
fonction des établissements mais pour
arriver à faire normalement les
contrôles des établissements comme on
l'a dit tout à l'heure de façon inopinée
de façon coordonnée en tout cas et puis
sur le plan national de l'organiser
notamment avec la cour des comptes qui
l'a proposé et puis d'autres organismes
et puis comme liga cnjf l'a fait pour
ces groupes je pense qu'ils ont fait un
travail en leur demande de le refaire
pour tous les groupes privés commerciaux
dans les deux ans s'il me sens beaucoup
plus important que de contrôler les 7500
établissements systématiquement qu'il le
fasse concrètement est complètement et
qu'on puisse aussi parler des autres
groupes que uniquement d'orpea
[Musique]
le pee wee il y avait une question aussi
le pilotage par la qualité je crois
qu'aujourd'hui c'est très important
beaucoup d'acteurs demande à ce que le
pilotage sera mis en place à part la
qualité la has a mis en place un
référentiel alors qui est un petit peu
lourd qui est un petit peu
difficile à mettre en place dans tous
les établissements mais qui permettrait
quand même de mettre en place certaines
obligations pour chaque établissement
par rapport à chaque résident il faut
absolument qu'on puisse contrôler la
qualité qui est apportée au niveau de
chaque résident en fonction de l'état
dans lequel il est aujourd'hui on
connaît les besoins des personnes mais
on apporte pas les moyens qu'il faut
pour y répondre et je crois que quand on
aura effectivement établi ce référentiel
des qualités quand on leur a mis en
place dans des établissements on
s'apercevra encore plus qu'il faut plus
de moyens plus de personnel mais ce
référentiel il existe il existe depuis
quelques mois il a été mis en place je
crois par la richesse en janvier ou
février et il permettra justement de
d'avoir sept contrôles par la qualité de
tous les établissements
madame béatrice jérôme et vous avez une
autre question
bah j'en aurais beaucoup
je ne sais pas est ce que vous avez
découvert des choses pendant votre
mission sur orpea sur vous vouliez avoir
des informations sur la collusion quand
tu elle entre certains membres ex
membres salariés du groupe orpea rs
voilà est-ce que comme vous êtes une
mission d' enquête vous avez vous avez
découvert une fois sur des éléments
inconnus non des éléments inconnus pas
vraiment puisque la plupart été révélée
dans le livre de victor casas nerfs on
voulait surtout la confirmation de ce
qui avait été annoncé mi qu'on a eu à
peu près
dans dans la plupart des cas je crois
qu'il y avait vraiment une volonté de
faire du profit avant tout
c'était tout était organisé pour qu'en
face
on rentabilise au maximum tout l'argent
qui était à portée et qui est des
détournements qui sont
tus ans a certainement scandaleux mais
je crois qu'aujourd'hui il ya une
plainte au niveau du procureur qui va
permettre d'aller beaucoup plus loin
dans l' enquête parce qu'il ya beaucoup
de 2,2 d'autres choses à vérifier
notamment dans des structures à
l'étranger dans les problèmes de
restauration ou autres qu'il que nous on
n'a pas eu à contrôler parce que c'était
pas notre rôle mais qu'il sera
intéressant de voir au niveau de la
justice
si vous voulez vous répondre mal à moi
je veux dire que j'ai pas découvert mais
j'étais vraiment très choqué de
l'ampleur et de la systématisation
des pratiques je m'explique je ne savais
pas qu'on était capable de diminuer un
grammage de viande par exemple diminué
des proportions
pour faire des économies et les placer
ensuite en produits financiers j'ai
entendu une directrice d pad témoigné
qu'elle avait été sanctionné parce
qu'elle avait dépassé 2 500 euros
annuels un budget alimentaire en
achetant du fromage blanc
supplémentaires on lui a dit madame
prenez des compléments alimentaires et
mettez le sur la rubrique santé c'est
remboursé par la sécurité sociale donc
voyez vous ce genre de sac d'exemple
j'allais dire anecdotes mais c'est pas
une anecdote c'est un exemple qui est
terrible qui est indigne et inacceptable
et qui ne doit pas perdurer donc les
contrôles de ce qui est financé par la
sécurité sociale il faut trouver les
moyens pour bien les attribuer là où ils
doivent aller c'est à dire sur le
bien-être et le suivi de la personne
âgée en ehpad
lorsque julien moschetti
à une question c'est le quotidien du
médecin
je voulais simplement savoir quelles
sanctions ou préconisées jusqu'où ça
peut aller finalement
la sanction
civile et la sanction justement on en a
parlé il faut pas que la sanction au
niveau d'un établissement d'un
établissement alors je parle pas des
établissements commerciaux différemment
des autres il faut pas qu'elle soit au
détriment des résidents je crois que
c'est une des choses les plus
importantes
par contre la sanction à partir du
moment où il ya des profits des profits
sur un établissement commercial d'un
kabyle lucratif il faut là qu'on puisse
mettre une sanction au niveau du siège
au ni le montant je ne peux pas le
l'évaluer comme ça je crois c'est plus
ça l'a peut-être
des gens de les juristes de le fixer et
de voir en fonction du profit qui a été
fait ou de l'anomalie qui a été mise en
place de devoir qu'elle est là le
montant qui peut être récupéré par
contre la sanction aussi là que je
voudrais qu'on puisse mettre en place
beaucoup plus facilement c'est la mise
en place d'une
on appelle ça du nhs
oui enfin une gradation mais quand on
l'enlève carrément au sein du léger sur
la place des hôtes ont
mis sous tutelle en famille sous tutelle
de l'établissement ou voire suppression
carrément de l'établissement dans
certains cas je pense que la mise sous
tutelle de l'établissement par est aussi
une solution qu'on devrait mettre en
place peut-être un petit peu plus
souvent dans certains cas bien sûr
le quotidien du médecin pas d'autres
questions
non je suis incompris ça irait jusqu'à
retirer les autorisations voilà c'est
cela
c'est déjà possible mais on ne fait pas
assez souvent mais je crois que là dans
certains cas il faudrait qu'on puisse le
mettre plus facilement en place et ça
aurait peut-être permis si on avait
connu toutes les dérives qui était dans
certaines structures notamment chez
européen serait peut-être permis
d'éviter que kiel
continuer à racheter des autorisations
ou à faire des transferts entre des
d'autres établissements aux yeux ça
aurait peut-être évité la progression
importante qu'il ya eu ces dernières
années
et qu'en est il du contrôle des
prestataires parce que le livre montre
alors on a interrogé les prestataires
effectivement on ne peut pas contrôler
les prestataires je crois que les
prestataires ceux là où il ya eu une
relation commerciale entre les acheteurs
et les commerciaux enfin les vendeurs
que les prix il faut essayer justement
de faire baisser les prix au maximum
mais dans l'intérêt des résidents
nous ce qu'on aurait voulu si vous
voulez c'est que quand hartmann ou
bastide n'apporte font des prix
importants on a envie de leur dire mais
fait est pris à toutes les structures
médico sociales et que tous les pc prix
là soient
facturés en baisse au niveau des
établissements et non pas au niveau du
siège alors on nous dit mais on sait
jamais quel est le montant total à la
fin d'année qui sera mis en place et
c'est pour ça qu'on mettait les rfa en
oeuvre mais c'est pas vrai parce qu'ils
savent exactement quel est le montant
qu'ils vont pouvoir déduire
chaque mois donc il le savait c'est pas
à la marge que la différence se fait
donc on voudrait que tout le monde
puisse profiter des remises que les les
les structures comme bastidou hartmann
eh bien ils fassent des réductions de
prix mais que tous bénéficient aux
résidents
si l'objectif c'est de donner plus et de
donner mieux en termes
alimentaire à des personnes âgées il n'y
a pas de problème pour des ristournes
c'est voilà c'est pareil pour des
protections 6 et
bénéfice de qui en fait
si les craintes quand on est responsable
d'une collectivité comme un département
ou autre et qu'on s'occupe de la gestion
de tous les collèges par exemple au
niveau de la restauration on essaie
draps des prix pour certaines choses
mais ça bénéficie
aux parents qui payera pas ça doit pas
bénéficier aux départements c'est pas
aller alors que le haut niveau des dix
sièges il profiter de ces réductions non
pas pour les résidents mais pour s'en
servir pour eux encore quelque chose
qu'ils quittaient qui est inacceptable
tout était fait pour faire du profit
même les laboratoires d'analysé tout
tout tout tout était fait le coiffeur de
verser une redevance tout le monde
en fin de compte on oeuvre pour que ce
secteur comme d'autres secteurs
d'ailleurs petite enfance par exemple ne
soient pas des cibles de marchés
financiers mais reste bien dans la
valeur de l'accompagnement
l'équipe du à la personne accueillie
là où pour l'enfance par exemple et on a
parlé tout à l'heure c'est un peu
différent c'est que sont pas les enfants
qui payent sont pas les parents qui
payent ces départements qui payent donc
à la limite
le ils peuvent pas faire de profit du
reste ya aucune structure commerciale ou
très peu qui celui de la protection de
l'enfance très peu il ya des structures
privées associatives mais il n'y a pas
de structures privées commerciales
marié n'a pas non plus beaucoup dans les
personnes handicapées me ferai peut-être
aussi mettre des contrôles et il y en a
par contre dans les structures d'accueil
de la petite enfance les crèches par
exemple les micro crèches en a vu le
scandale récent sur lyon là aussi il
faudra peut-être
activités contrôle un peu plus que ce
qui existe aujourd'hui
est ce qu'il y à d'autres questions
est ce que voudrait ce que voudrait
surtout en conclusion si vous dire que
on est très satisfait en tout cas
d'avoir pu travailler sur ce dans ce
domaine
malheureux de voir qu'on s'aperçoit que
maintenant des dérives qu'on a eu dans
ce secteur
stupéfait de voir que des personnes ont
pu agir de la sorte depuis autant
d'années avec la seule volonté de faire
du profit
parce que quand on nous parle de volonté
de qualité d'accueillir et où
on a du mal à y croire et par contre
cette volonté de faire du profit elle et
elle nous paraît
scandaleuse je crois qu'on peut être un
groupe privé commercial s'occuper d'un
hébergement de qualité de restauration
en faisant pourquoi pas un peu de profit
mais il faut jamais que ce soit au
détriment des résidents ça c'est notre
obligation c'est de billets sont des
collectivités cette obligation d élus et
c'est une obligation de deux des
parlementaires que nous sommes de
contrôler
merci pour votre attention et puis donc
bonne lecture du rapport et ils ne
seront à votre disposition près
[Musique]
merci beaucoup